[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci beaucoup et bien cette chanson me
rappelle ou plutôt la façon dont Guy
anne-emarie et Raymond ont très
gentiment chanté avec moi me rappelle
une nuit où autant que je me souvienne
j'ai bu d'un trait de finalo et tris
whisky et puis après quelques Porteau
avec
Johnny derrière sa guitare je le voyais
tout petit
oh quelle
nuit je me souviens d'avoir dansé le
chat chap chap avec une fille qui
ressemblait à
Pétula tout en pleurant je lui ai confié
ma vie oh oh oh
oh quelle nuit tout çaa est arrivé parce
qu'on t'a raconté on m'avait vu avec une
jolie femme
tu as voulu te venger et tu n'es pas
rentré alors je t'ai cherché voilà le
drame petit jour je suis
rentré tu m'attendais sur le palier en
pyjama quand tu m'as vu tu m'as tendu
les
bras quelle
nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
puis je t' prouver que c'est de femm
nétait tout simplement qu'une de mes
secrétaires et toi tu m'as avoué que
pour me faire marcher tu dinais ce soirl
avec ta
grand-mère
de jours je me suis mis à l'utre bichie
mais en une nuit j'ai découvert et j'ai
compris que tu es mon indispensable
amour oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
pour la
vie